throwing some darts and go to the
fitting some bars
hey throwing in that dark my fart is
your bars and goes into Mars hey what's
up check us out on the road I got hella
tour dates San Francisco September 8th
Tulsa Oklahoma Oklahoma City Dallas
Austin Houston San Antonio Arkansas
Fayetteville Arkansas Peoria Madison
Minneapolis Milwaukee Vegas Toronto
Oakland Eugene Oregon LA San Diego
Charlotte Hattiesburg Mississippi New
Orleans get your tickets now Hannibal
Burres calm
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
we in Florida [ __ ] what's up another
episode of a handsome Rambla podcast I'm
your host Hannibal Buress and I am your
co-host
Tony tram get good friend first time on
the show oh my god
welcome set it off Chris set it off come
on Joe you know I ain't using no [ __ ]
like this yeah I love it
I didn't know we will go future Richard
Pryor slash Dick Gregory Seinfield type
of mr. hedge bird type of guy got
debited Tony over you Tony helped me get
my black belt yeah in DJing you know
everybody can fight - yeah so he can't
fight found that out last night yeah
Tony got one of those things that what
does that thing called what's called a
Mook Jong dummy mr. Miyagi was all you
ever see it man the movie yeah it man
yeah but out but I thought it was an uh
in Karate Kid two on one part of it when
he was doing the thing to tease Ralph
Macchio I know what you're talking about
now no it's Chinese and the karate is
Japanese Japanese okay - now you feel
the current attitude okay we got
Taekwondo well you know what I heard in
Japan you had to have black blood in you
to be a samurai or African blue that's
what they say yeah we can google this
you know what I'm glad we here because
everybody listening it is Google Google
that this our audience is a very google
and audience way they'll say we listened
to we heard you meant to something we
look that up so thanks for letting us
know about that well I got some [ __ ] for
real yeah you read a lot
I'm not saying in an accusatory way but
you you I see you always posted online
about different books and you always put
me on to some stuff historically that I
didn't know yeah but I only do that
because you put me on the stuff that's
historical you fed me when we first met
you know me you told me your name how
about eating people I still get that a
lot of the time from people he told me
he said I'm Anna but actually I'm a
Carthaginian King and I went on my own
mission then all I had to know was he
was named after him and talking like
that that it was a black King because I
all the time I used to hear by Hannibal
in school like most people I thought it
was this white guy Conqueror in the land
yeah he'd come to find out he's from a
place called Carthage and Carthage is a
present-day what Tunisia and looked at
Africa Africa yeah and basically Rome
got rid of it you know I mean so there's
some history there so and you made me
when once I did that going back to
Carthage I ended up finding history
further back the net and up from that
you know I mean whether it's Greek or
you know going into religion going into
spirituality all of that man you feel me
so I thank you you fear me thank thank
you set it all free Shane it we need the
true but I people don't get our real
history anyway it's uh still people
still say this [ __ ] to me are you lying
to me no I'm not lying to you
no I do lie to strangers sometimes for
fun he's both through yeah just just if
you don't want to really start I had a
driver recently and I just wish I didn't
tell him I was a comedian I didn't think
I should have said because once people
I'll talk about traveling never you were
there there that what do you do for a
living why are you traveling so much and
then I said I should just say consultant
he went right to the routine in there he
didn't go to routine what he was just
saying oh I drove such a certain I've
met such a subtle I saw s'appelle back
in the day in the West Village
he was so
you ever met him Oh why'd he leave his
show Oh
people say it was this you think it was
and I'm just back on my phone right now
I saw this one comedian and it was a
long ride to is about an hour and a half
two hour ride he didn't go the whole
time but it was just where I just kind
of wish I said consultant I always [ __ ]
with my drivers cuz most of the time is
like an immigrant you know there and not
to say immigrant in a bad way because
the people here down there colonies of
American immigrants but you know it
whatever wherever they from I always
find that wedding from it didn't just
start a conversation about like what
before I came here I think with your
front brother he was like oh I'm from
Haiti yeah I say you from Haiti well if
you don't get your John Justin Lanie's
to [ __ ] no but your face as out of here
but was I said that but don't y'all that
don't know that y'all like the Google
make sure you google to um you know
about the French Revolution but Google
Haitian Revolution and you'll see both
of those two names pop up Toussaint
L'Ouverture and John Tesar Lanie's you
know they were very instrumental in the
exhibition they were the leaders of it
lead well and that's the thing everybody
they were leaders as far as we are
talking about organizing and being one
person to point at but I don't think a
revolt really should have just a leader
I think everybody is revolting at the
same time so there shouldn't be a leader
like we just make an example they say
Frederick Douglass or Harriet Tubman
were abolitionists in my mind I thought
every black person does asleep should be
an abolition - yeah you feel me right
but that may be complicated but it needs
to be some infrastructure somebody to
send out all the handwritten letters
somebody do that
somebody got a handle supplies you know
somebody got to talk to the wholesaler
[Music]
dope game I don't know what brought all
this about you know I mean because we
have to do this even in the shows and I
don't really mean to be like that just
be speaking on history like that you
know I used to feel bad about it you
made me feel good about it you feeling
because people be like me anybody trying
to hit like that [ __ ] cuz you get some
people that's overly woke yes you know
if you I think if you in comedy
if you talk about stuff that's
interesting to you and you able to spin
it and have a good take on it that's
gonna transfer that's gonna is go to
connect because people gonna say oh he
really believes in this [ __ ] well
there's something this about serious
history yeah versus it could be
something trivial about zippers or
something but it's right if people yo
dis muhfucka see my he's serious about
them zippers yeah I believe I believe
that he feels that way about cuz he's
saying that [ __ ] with his heart but you
know but someday even in video belongs
I think longer some things are true yeah
you know it doesn't matter how they feel
about it you know I'm saying you still
have to respect that you know what I
mean it's like it's not opinion and
that's and that's the thing people are
stating opinions about some things
that's different from stating some
things or opinions I just say that you
know I don't know maybe I'm saying it
different maybe I'm confusing myself I
don't know what I'm just happy to be
here yeah man I used to be in jail but
I'm out free I love it
how long you in jail for see I did like
six seventeen year old you know
seventeen what happened talk to me
I want the streets want to know what the
[ __ ] happening back what happened in
Miami and I've been talking about it on
stage for the past couple weeks is that
uh you know imagine arguing with a
person and that person has handcuffs
they win the argument they have had cuz
she's like oh every time I didn't know I
didn't bring mine I didn't bring mine I
didn't know we were doing that I sort of
knew I didn't know you were gonna do
that based on this type are but dammit
who end up having to footage of the
phone was there a few people out there
was art Bowser so there's a few people
on the street next I'm not originally it
was it was a camera angle now I was
looking at whether it was that a camera
angle now somebody phones you talking
about for the the initial thing you've
been I'm looking at
face you know Xena you was like hey oh
this is [ __ ] that's a hell of a body cam
footage oh wait a minute hold on do you
just what I was looking at body cam
footage yeah you mean to tell me they
got body cam footage for a Hannibal
Burres case yeah but we still can't get
the body cam footage
Michael goddamn Brown what the hell is
going on out here okay I think that's
when they started the body cams back
then after the Michael Brown thing well
you know it don't matter cuz isn't that
like a battle of our pixels or something
like that it's not like the police got
the body isn't that like the police uh
got the body camera in this before yeah
and then it's like our regular cameras
are just Android cameras I mean she's
it's the same footage it's the truth
good finish what some words with the I
had too many words yes I went over my
words had already made my point I had
already made my point and I said what I
needed to say but then I kept on going
with the words you got it though
sometimes you gotta you gotta know
winter
no one holding win and leave we got to
leave up you got to leave when you're
out I was already up cuffs around the
hand was already up and I went all in
you were far away from this guy you
couldn't put no cuffs on you from the
footage I saw I saw you clap those hands
and you said I'm Hannibal Buress I said
that's my mother [ __ ] talking to the
camera I was talking to the can I wasn't
talking to him why would I say that
yo YouTube was sorry Hannibal Buress I
don't know
you know it might be six months from how
would hours together we have a very
loose production schedule I keep all
good messages
where's the podcast I just haven't
worked I keep going I keep getting dm's
like is it over is it done just call me
no you know I told people I was coming
down here to mess with y'all guys you
know I mean yeah for the show everybody
kept saying
so if you see Hannibal tell them him and
Tony we're waiting on that album
[Laughter]
[Music]
Lucien
I will cover solo ever made soon I will
cover soul ever MailChimp
probably jo-jo fit come on coming with
that new [ __ ] oh oh let's get HB Tony
tread on the beat
i'ma split forest Miami nobody got
Tsar's boat my favorite movies cars oh
this is a simple yeah
mr. mr. wavy shoutout did it just like a
little interview I thought it was just
gonna be like some hey you know fan
interview whatever and then I mentioned
that we were working out and then the
news outlets were like totally trim have
a burns if I can drop that let's do it
[Music]
people
pressure on this but seriously I want
y'all to know just how many p.m. on the
plane it was 15 I don't start to talking
to two people 15 people by the end of
this conversation all overlays the album
out is it were talking about album like
the [ __ ] Tony said you know Tony no like
I said we're lightly working on
something that Tony Tony what so
nationality you career right yeah okay
okay North Korea South Korea see if you
if you ask somebody if there's North or
South you're basically asking are you a
good one or a bad one go with it the
only reason that is a real thing now
because Korea before was no offense our
Korea it was Korea and then somebody
came trying to break that place up and
to try to break the people of the
Communists you know you know how come
you just don't know what that mean but I
think I know what I mean North half is
communist bottom half is camera I didn't
know that I used to read it like it was
comunist but go here help I didn't know
I'll just pronounce it wrong yo think
about how
focused and ambitious in such a terrible
way you have to be you think about how
some people just say I want to start my
own business where it was a group of
people yo let's split this country it's
a weird [ __ ] let's split the country up
much legwork that's a think about what
it takes just a start your own don't see
your juice stores some [ __ ] that takes a
lot of [ __ ] to get a juicer you gotta
get partners you gotta get fruit
connects you gotta get Cheers
you gotta get stainless steel [ __ ] but
then the split up a country and put a
wall on that [ __ ] and got armed guards
24/7 that's a lot of work just to split
a country that's some guy now I'm
thinking about even about America I
starting a garden you got to get rid of
the tree you a lot of stuff just to do
it regular tasks is stupid to split a
country what about the people they don't
leave that they don't leave if you're in
North Korea you don't leave so if you
meet a Korean right I would say 99% of
the chance they're not North Korean
because then you can't leave damn you
know I did not know that [ __ ] out it's
like they're locked up it's like prison
over there damn that's nothing then they
went in with the cameras maybe two weeks
ago when it was on CNN you know saying
CNN or a Chilean I think seeing in and
they started interviewing the people
that are in North Korea I mean like
literally it still looks like everything
you know you're saying they lock down
you know they're not just in prisons or
whatever but they're still on the beach
or whatever so they went to a group of
people on the beach maybe seven of them
they said hey we know that you guys
don't don't don't they say you guys
don't leave here do you know anything
about America he was like I know
anything what about basketball
he was like basketball he said yeah you
know anything about basketball that's
what I knew they were like because I
know goddamn kim young-hee no Dennis
Rodman and well I mean the people there
are very limited to what they're allowed
to say do but the United States was
there with this with this camera now and
they on them and what
raka was he said you don't know anything
about basketball they said no they don't
time he had a Toronto Raptors very own
that was I mean I think kim jong kim
jeong-hoon does because he's a big
basketball fan but as far as like the
people there they're all constant lock
that is crazy because they you know
because he's like a god over there they
treat it it's like religion so it people
are people are convinced that the
government could read their minds oh
yeah it's like that locked out so it's
like they can't even they're not leave
even allowed to think about their
country being [ __ ] hey that's how [ __ ]
up it is a little man what they must be
thinking about it in some way cuz they
had a group of kids and make no mistake
about it they had um arcade in there you
know me and the kids the plan is arcade
game like they just shooting at the game
son and the guy for seeing it come from
the front of them like hey how you guys
doing what are you guys doing they were
playing the game they said what are you
doing is that we're killing the enemy
I'm talking like like with a machine gun
and the white guy said who's the enemy
that boy stop easy Americans well I got
scared oh [ __ ] did he say
african-americans when you see the when
you mostly see footage of North Korea is
usually like filtered footage they'll
take you to these like fake ok years
where it looks like it's okay you know
it looks like it's it's all the way in
or doing nice but in reality the place
is a [ __ ] it's it's a dead zone yeah
so when you when you see footage that's
like allowed footage it's not it's like
little camps that they set up okay it's
like it's like studio they would studio
they got me they got me they got me with
them they got me with down well cuz I
thought that was genuine for a second I
just [ __ ] up over there you know that
[ __ ] it's crazy
I wish I didn't eat half of that weed
rice krispies treat before the show you
want to make a song
shake that off auto - shake that off
smoke we met back in Chicago back in
probably what Oh 500 folk if I had a
five I end up going out - um maybe it's
Oh four or five I'm not around it when I
just started though cuz I got I got into
it I got kidnapped and [ __ ] it got hit
side - he had a concussion so I got a
little bit my memory Oh real [ __ ]
happens to the best of us we met and I'm
trying to think how about what did we
meet at the comedy club first and then I
saw you again down at the college cuz we
were doing a show down at armed at
Southern Illinois a something on
University mean you two more comedians
on the show and you were doing it you
gonna do a guest by the something like
that and then we didn't know who was
gonna host it all a [ __ ] host it you
was like okay let's get this straight
you guys are you know you've been doing
this a long time when you're at my
school I'm really not gonna pay for the
show but I'm supposed to host this yet
and you still hosted it and hosted this
[ __ ] like our [ __ ] real host
Mila Nelson in the back like Nick do you
see this [ __ ] I don't think you do it
show maybe one or two shows if that you
know saying you weren't a lot of shows
bring for me and for the lover that you
did it on you didn't know I don't think
you knew how much you did on the stage
you know what I'm saying we knew it
because we've been into the game a
little longer you know what I mean but
that [ __ ] that's transferred to
everything that y'all now really
basically when people see when people
say you say you find it out we already
know it you know that means someone's
just funnier than others I mean you
ain't funnier than me but there's no
problem you everybody can be Jesus Jesus
did you say G Z Z Z Z I'm talking about
say Jesus I'm talking about that
decreases that crispy white one sees a
bougie explain that to me Jesus is
jealous of you yeah what do you guys so
you got whatever you want yeah sure hey
that sound like a that's not like a trap
hook where Jesus is jealous of me
they'll be my commanders I'm good mad
but it's polarizing cuz some people say
oh he don't really mean these zealots
over he's just exaggerated exaggeration
but you get a real it's not a shot at
Jesus he's just kind of you know how it
is it's just a rapper saying something I
always wonder though like if you ever
could see like a nuh-uh
in a religious that have a religious dog
you have to put yourself in biblical
times I always I never knew what year
biblical times was because people always
say well you know it was back in
biblical times you say BC just for
Christ [ __ ] hold on now Hannibal from
Carthage just bc time we talking to them
that's 200 BC at least but so even I
mean subscribe to the time you have to
just be like oh yeah Jesus
like louis c.k got that bit but it's
like christians one you say cuz
christians one you know how could I know
Christians one we're at what year is it
right now but that might be too deep for
the people they may not know it you
feeling me I got you I know what real
Christians are you know I mean real
Christians are um well I guess we're
real Romans got they with Romans before
they were Christmas you know what I mean
now you have to go to what may wrong the
people that may Rome or the Vandals that
came down into wrong and they killed the
Christians that were in Rome
so they came to just vandalized vacated
that's why they call fountain they came
in vandals and he left murder hey
shoutout to John Henry Clark that
doesn't scholar that I learned that from
we just came to break some [ __ ] but now
[ __ ] it no no next they were still no
they a vendor is destroying everything
so they're taking lives and everything
okay that's the murderer
that's a murderer to break [ __ ] okay
look he's not vandalize that
accidentally the murders muhfuckas you
emerge with murder takes over all the
other crimes they'll be like you got
charged with murder and also robbery
well I put it like this when they came
in those vandals came in because
murderers burn garden
hey this is vandalizing I'm a mandolin
[Laughter]
difference big big difference these
murderers pay now
you just throw people were Christians
and then they murdered those Christians
yeah now follow me here once they
murdered those Christians they weren't
car vandals anymore mm-hmm they were
called Christians what so now you have
to stay light it sounds crazy to see a
Christian with vandal or even murder
somebody right but I can show you some
Ku Klux Klan Christians they probably
have done it Hey all right I'm just
saying Ku Klux Klan or Christians are
they well they burned my church so I
knew it I thought they burned out George
cuz we had better music but maybe it was
something different yeah you think there
is I mean I'm not religious but I'm
serious I wonder if there if there is a
God or Jesus and he sees people like the
Klan he's like we don't really [ __ ]
with y'all we don't really [ __ ] with
y'all but I can't say nothing but I
don't [ __ ] which I like their fam y'all
needs to chill when they started the
Bible making different different
versions of it man you know I mean
that's where everything came from you
know so we just got to find out truth I
want a black Jesus personally yeah I
want one have you seen one black Jesus
yeah Jesus
Kanye yo that's me that's myself that
was a well that's my sample yeah I was
Calle doing these days
yo he's finally cooking up some music
it's cooking up some music went you
in Michaela how long you been doing
comedy man I've been doing this [ __ ]
like maybe 17 yes 17 18 years now man
cuz I can't just say I've been doing a
consistent you know I started out doing
comedy by going AWOL I was in I was in
the Navy so I went AWOL in the Navy
doing comedy shows so when I went AWOL
in the Navy this when I came to Chicago
wait that's back up a little bit back it
up so you just you went AWOL you just I
was on the ship first I was on the same
ship that um Top Gun was on the USS
Enterprise and what's the I know I care
what's the acronym AWOL stand for Oh a
wo is therefore absent without leave
absent without leave yeah because
because leave is what you have to take
when you're in the military you a you
literally have to write a request [ __ ]
to ask for permission to leave from the
captain then they give you permission to
leave but when I wrote mine for the
dates they said they only leave that I
could take was Christmas leave and
summer leave so I said well I'm gonna
take weather leave and they said what
was weather leave I said whether you
give it to me or not [ __ ] I'm from the
leave and I love it when they walk you
know I went to Chicago actually I went
to DC first in with the Chicago so you
wouldn't fool anyone I went for a walk
quit the first time the first time I
went AWOL three times the first time I
went AWOL this is real before before I
even went AWOL still I went through the
méditerranée
you talk so fast that I don't think
you'd be realizing what you're saying
well maybe you don't realize the gravity
of what you're saying thank you and you
be says it and then it's like nope we
gotta pull back and talk about that I
only went AWOL because I had just came
off a maid cruise I may accrue the short
for Mediterranean cruise in the military
and you know my grandma had just died
and I'm on the ship in less than 24
hours after my grandmother feeling or
I'm on the ship
seeing the world now yeah and I got a
chance to go through Spain Italy France
Egypt Greece you know Kuwait I mean
everyone mean not Kuwait Dubai you know
I mean
I just got a chance to see the world and
saw so much history and saw how every
time I went to another country United
States got a base in every country right
and no country has a base in the United
States so my mind just started being
open to the world and I was like you
know what I'm I can get paid more
working at Walmart so [ __ ] this I'm
leaving I don't like it I'm out of here
and I never got to work in my field I
was an electrician mate and now the next
thing I was on the side of [ __ ] painting
the ship I'll say what the [ __ ] part
of the game wait that that's interesting
why isn't there any other military base
in the US we try to come in not just the
United States is it cuz we just run [ __ ]
yeah man you know you know run [ __ ] you
you you run [ __ ] by separating the
people first you can't run it if you
don't separate the people like North and
South Korea regardless of anything North
to South Korea or steal Koreans now that
the problem is y'all can't just speak to
each other you feel me because if
everybody could speak to each other I'm
pretty sure people be like look get Kim
out the way so we could talk once the
wall now I got Grandmama's over there we
still got families now that are
separated your family and anybody who
can't have and when you hear people say
stupid [ __ ] like blow them [ __ ]
up that's that dumb [ __ ] right there you
know I got ancestors on the other side
it's important right now just a speech
all up seriously and when I tell you I'm
on the nuclear carrier an aircraft
carrier we have planes on there we got
at least 200 300 planes on the f-14 Jets
f-16 Hornets a6 intruders like real-deal
plane not to mention the nuclear weapons
you got on there not to mention a
Gatling gun I used to have to clean the
weapons you know what I mean like when
you going down into the weapons into a
room you have to clean the weapons
polish them off but if you put too much
static on it it can blow up you feel me
I'm like that just took my desire to
clean this [ __ ] all right - have you
ever cleaning job so I just end up
seeing it man and then we looking at the
news and we went to war and that was the
car that this wasn't Desert Storm at
this time this was called Desert Shield
and it was you know joint force attack
with Navy SEALs Marines everybody you
know what I mean from now where are you
50
I just know oh you were talking about
when you were okay it's just period
about a period of the military state we
have Florida right now right now when I
was telling y'all about a place called
and since this is a googling crowd
Google this Fort Negro is then is in the
Florida for Negroes and we talking down
1812 MB 1813 this is when the British in
the United States are fighting the
difference is the British has black real
dear runaway slaves and stuff like that
fighting with Great Britain you know I
mean because we was explained right look
some are we just say buy some white
people but some more white people came
over here saying we'll let you free if
you fight with us so we don't fight with
them right then the United States start
putting a couple of black guys to fight
for them to make it seem as if well we
got black people fighting - black people
would never fight to keep themselves a
slave so let's just get that out the way
but my point is this place in Fort Negro
were all black people the United States
dispatched the Navy to come down and
when you talk about the Navy and
military some people in the military
that are generals and captains become to
be presidents one guy name was Andrew
Jackson he was one of the guys on the
Navy ships to come down there to
decimate everybody else so with that
being known and especially if you're in
Florida when I heard about all of the
blacks that got killed because Great
Britain left and went to great back to
Great Britain which they never did
that's the lie Great Britain left the
United States and went to Canada because
they own that too that's what I think
you know what I mean there's no big no
big problem your basic knowledge you can
look at it yeah you couldn't track ships
back then you just just trust as
somebody said they was going where they
were going
that's real talk man but Andrew Jackson
he was a he was a part of that right
there Fort Negro man you know and that's
why I feel about us right now we down
here we very we I don't want to just say
just conscious you feel me but we are we
are true tell us you know I'm saying and
we keep it real you know what I mean not
being raised not being prejudiced none
of that you know I mean it's just
telling the truth and having our own
opinions you know what I mean and ain't
nothing wrong with it is that right or
wrong
talk to me that's right it's right you
asked me which one asked me well I was
gonna ask you you say you went AWOL
three times yeah the first time so you
left and then they found you know
brought you back only were AWOL because
the ways to get out of the middle
back then they had the Don't Ask Don't
Tell policy which means if the if you
tell them you gay you can get out so you
come you're yelling I was going to I was
going to do that but right when I got up
there cuz all the guys talked about it
it was literally like fifty of us just
saying look if you tell me you get you
can get out of here now
you know chipping my nails and when I
remember and we and the captain on my
[ __ ] was captain McCullough the big guy
that went in before me you wanted all
white guys you can't eat went in there
and he came out but when he came out I'm
getting my [ __ ] ready I'm looking like
open the man act like a [ __ ] right here
I got a really gotta [ __ ] about here I
don't like this name I'm trying to get a
fake ass accident everything do you know
that the guy that went in before me did
the exact same thing but then the
captain came out and when the captain
came out he just looked at me like cuz
he knew me you know I'm saying we talked
all the time I worked on this on the
captain's elevator he was like he didn't
think I was there to talk to him too he
thought I was just there to fix
something or just dead and I was he was
like you know what Chris don't you just
hate the fruity ones the next we have
some crazy stuff going on on the ship
man you gotta remember you in the middle
of the water
so it's gonna be some crazy stuff
happening the crazy [ __ ] that I saw with
my homeboy jumped off the ship you can
get off of the ship you can get out of
the military if you jump off the ship
yeah so my homeboy or if you fall off
the ship my homeboy when they jump clean
off that [ __ ] that's not a walk that's
not it would eat was considered crazy or
mentally unstable I wanted to do it but
it was sharks in the water he just
wasn't scared like literally you can see
all type of animals in there so then
they just get him out of the water no
seal swinging got him because when
somebody get get off of the ship a man
overboard we have Navy SEALs on hardship
we got nothing we don't age like that
[Music]
that's exactly what I thought got my
seal and we had real seals on the ship
and I got to say shoutout to the SEAL
Team six this is real right now because
I want to let people know in the
military when people saying people are
disrespectful to people in the military
you got to remember some people have
died you know I'm saying and I respect
some of these guys to the utmost you
feeling like on one Mountain one Navy
SEAL his name was Steven Voigt and I
used to talk to him every morning you
know I mean cuz the seals are get to
talk to the regular enlisted you know I
mean he'd never complained about nothing
bro you know I mean he he eat the same
food that everybody else had he didn't
go to the gallery he didn't get no extra
privileges even though he know he's out
here killing [ __ ] but you know
I'm saying for the safety of his family
not for the safety of just America for
the safety of listen bro I got a kid at
home I got a family I'm doing this to
feed them in him
I found power because he told me a lot
of black history that I didn't know you
know I'm saying about black people so I
got to honor that he saw things I
couldn't see even goes into Asian
history he told me about them going to
Cambodia and I could speak about this
now because he's passed away now and he
told me there's I know he ain't lyin he
said he went to Cambodia and in Cambodia
to the same place where the air MORTAL
KOMBAT we were playing the Mortal Kombat
game that's how the conversation got
started when you see Liu Kang the place
where he's from that's almost an ancient
place called Angkor and kawatte matter
of fact and how it looks it looks the
same he's the one who told me that this
is where a lot of history ill you feel
me and it got covered up for a while
cuz I was thinking like what if they got
something like this in Cambodia I'm
pretty sure that that the world would
have found this he said now it was the
jungle there you know I mean and these
fig trees covered everything you know
fig trees are like real big trees they
cover everything they start growing on
there
all over this house overtime you know
what I mean so they end up cutting the
trees down went in found the relics you
know but in Cambodia history with the
United States and you know this because
you agent two ages they're all Asians
history not really well I mean to say
that I'm just trying to give more props
I don't know [ __ ] Cambodia there was a
time when they started killing the
people in Cambodia man they killed
everybody with glasses broke you feel me
because they did they didn't want to
risk leaving some teachers alive so some
people were taking off the glasses
putting on regular clothes going out
acting like they were farmers and stuff
like that you know the mean this is real
history but I respect that guy Steven
boy rest in peace - Steven Voigt
if you never knew him you can google
this if you want to he was on the USS
Enterprise and ain't got a son man I
gotta find his son one day you see that
was it about Cambodia there was a there
was a documentary about one of the
executioner's yeah I'm like yeah he
would use wires and show like yes dark
is [ __ ] yeah but didn't I say it wasn't
about it you know did I say that about
even even um the Holocaust you know I'm
saying they say the Holocaust was the
worst
no but this documentary was about one
executioner who killed thousands of
people in Cambodia yeah I think it might
be not I mean you know you guys I saw it
was W in a Southeast Asian country but
the documentary was about him just
walking through like he got so used to
marking [ __ ] it wasn't even
like he like it was second nature from
you yeah so I put him up here and save
some of my energy I put him around the
tree and then just you do it like this
hey it was he was a barehanded he was a
barehanded [ __ ] executioner Hey oh
that's terrible yeah you know I said oh
that's terrible man I forgot the name of
the documentary but it's like now you
like documentaries are we being a man we
talk about history too much no I why not
alright cuz I don't know some people
don't like that but I like to talk about
40 minute
though well you might want to get your
you know plugs in look it up I just
change I just change my Instagram name
can I give my Instagram yeah my
Instagram name followed me at Chris
Jones funny you're very active yeah
there's a video every look at me I'm
making eggs you know the deal this is
safe though you don't exam with this
inside of here I couldn't wait because I
do this already on the daily basis you
know I mean the world would love to see
behind-the-scenes stuff you feel yeah so
if you want to see some
behind-the-scenes stuff
log on to Chris Jones funny you feel you
know follow Hannibal Burres goddammit
father god damn it to get them to follow
god damn it Marcos following everybody
and I love y'all man appreciate and I'm
here you know why did it take me so long
for the world find out who I am you feel
me
I gotta get prop them a dollar how the
boy I thank you for that how about you
finish that show man I feel like I made
enough yeah not really how long you been
in Atlanta no I've been in the latter
downspouts and now ten years now I left
Chicago went straight to Atlanta you
know and when I got down to Atlanta I
just started over man I basically it was
just like I stopped using smokey and
just used Chris Jones you know the mean
and all the comedians down there was
just like oh you know you Chris I knew
some you know they may be like you know
some of the some of the some of the guy
that we saw traveling but not that many
of them travel maybe like two or three
the rest of them they tried to treat me
like a new comic so I know I'm I'm good
no different than you go somewhere you
went to New York you went up there and
whoop their ass on stage you know I mean
they was looking like we're gonna see if
you're gonna prove yourself so basically
just went through all level you know I'd
like to go to where the best at show me
who the best comedians are that's what
the [ __ ] I want to be cuz if you work
the best ass and you'll be considered
the best
that's what Bernie Mac did what do you
think about Atlanta Clark and Atlanta
crowds really rough yeah you get
somebody will jump up in Atlanta say boy
you ain't [ __ ]
see that's why don't [ __ ] with comedy
it's scary
there's some community say kill yourself
right kill you like you said that's not
that's the all-time favorite right there
man that's that's just a staple that's a
staple right there like there are
different processes now you know what I
mean like there you got you got
somewhere you use some music to come on
you know I mean once the person gets
booed in Atlanta you still have a chance
to redeem yourself
after that they like [ __ ] that we're
gonna boo you now now we're gonna boo
you they don't come looking just to boo
now it used to be bad like that now it's
just it's pretty much level feel you
feel me but you can't be no [ __ ] you
know I mean if you if you if you wet and
man it off and I know it sounds crazy
like well how the [ __ ] the people in
Atlanta how the [ __ ] these country
[ __ ] get to judge and Lana's
not just country people Atlanta is
everybody from all walls popping off
everywhere you know I mean so basically
that's what it is you got a diverse
crowd well I thought New York was a
diverse crowd but you're only diverse in
New York you know yeah I knew when I
went to New York I said yeah I just got
here on an underground train on the
Underground Railroad and some lady said
you mean the subway I think that's what
y'all called it and I was really being
real that I didn't mean to say it in no
type of way you know what I mean it's
just culture shocks man you know that
mean but I like it I like it in Atlanta
we got the rapper we got the music we
got the TVs I saw zombies [ __ ] at the
mall down dog they feel walking dead
down there literally you know and that's
new Hollywood is amigos with their 24/7
224 song you know you know deadly record
label QC you know Julio Jones affiliated
with them too right oh yeah me neither
but I got a picture with them in the
migos I think other people Chris Brown
did a really long album any I think
artists have been doing that lately I
read is to manipulate the streaming
system so if you're yes if your album
has more tracks then it gets more
overall streams which counts towards the
the ranking so what a complete album so
let's make that let's make our album 100
songs just make it a double album
no just one album 100 songs listen
because in all the plays count towards
the album you gotta have a fat ass CD
that can't even seconds someone be so
just quick ass so hello I will agree let
me do a skit on it long as I do a skit
on it just wants to do a quick song yo
this my thirties right now of course
crazy yo
so we just call what if we called all
the tracks track just the track number
the track one track one track one track
one track there's the first track this
is what you play winners up first track
will decide if you listen to the rest of
my songs will you go to track - what it
do with go from skip the track one
attract folk how many tracks we got
about forty four tracks go listen to
track 32 this is the intro is track 1 I
got a track 92 - hey yo 22 what about
the fives 58 5 and 25 open the track to
the lag got the hunted song out polka
powder powder TAC play has a weird add a
bar okay it wasn't that great okay
they raced our bar and imma still its
fate yeah track second with track 14
double up to 7 yo did we slip in another
track cuz people wouldn't even listen to
all the tracks 14 and 81 is the same
well track 7 is great tracks where was
Lane we made a hundred souls this is the
first one you know we all
[Music]
this is chapter one
[Music]
track it up truck one that [ __ ] just
takes me to a whole nother zone I feel
like we start a whole nother show every
time we go to a whole can we do the
mobile podcast we ride around it'll be a
different setup but you could do a
podcast in the car yeah I've seen it
I've seen it anywhere do podcast
anywhere your daughter's party man I've
seen a couple videos your daughter take
does she take after your mannerisms and
rhythms I saw once I I tell my daughter
all boys have AIDS that's what I do you
know I'm thinking I'm trying to prepare
her for the like I really prepare my
daughter to be in the lesbian that's
what I'm really trying to do right now I
mean I just don't want to get attacked I
mean I'm pretty
maybe we'll adopt a baby I got nieces
nephews the family's gonna survive I'm
cool with you can I put her in martial
arts
oh I don't want it to get a black belt
wet belt is it Tony did you break the
wood that's in Taekwondo and no you do
that like on a white belt like breaking
wood soon as she get ready to break that
warp out I'm taking out of class that
wooden I just wanted but you don't want
her to be able to hurt you because I'll
try it
it's we would you got a no I'm gonna let
her in just enough to get that
consciousness to break that water so she
can break a [ __ ] you fear me but
she's not gonna be able to take me down
you feelin me cuz I'm gonna be getting
older
yes I can't have my daughter whooping my
ass I mean what if you owed her she'd be
able to neutralize you with that wood
shop well she got no hair not if I grab
that hand
[Laughter]
Matt listen right I think about doing I
can't I can't wait for it to grow up doe
cuz I know I'm preparing myself when she
go to school all this history I'm
talking yes sooner she goes as soon as
you go to classical okay class
tomorrow's Columbus Day [ __ ] that I want
to hit by the Moors my daddy told me
that [ __ ] I wanna hear that Cleopatra
[ __ ] I want to hear about the Moors tell
me about melanin [ __ ] so you're
teaching her like real real hair real
history that's good really is to be [ __ ]
because we don't get enough of that
in the education system mmm cuz I
haven't I mean like I learned on my own
like oh [ __ ] the Japanese did a
holocaust from the Koreans and I never
knew about that oh they don't teach
about the concentration camp oh we got
these people on I said look we got to
talk about this one of y'all might have
to pull out your phones for this this is
this is very serious you know that after
the Holocaust all of the German soldiers
came to Alabama
Aliceville Alabama all not when I say
all of the souls I mean the Special
Forces soldiers the ones that were
putting Jews into the concentration
camps the gas chambers they were called
the SS you know I mean and I even know
what if one of the commanders his name
was Rommel I'm we blessed now because I
had a chance to grow up in Atlas V
Alabama that's the same town that I'm
from yeah so I learned history from a
real Nazi not and the only reason I'm
saying this now because when you
thinking up a Nazi soldier you're
thinking up the man with the uniform and
the gun but what happened before he had
the uniform in the gun Hitler made
everybody become a soldier you feel me
so this mean teachers lawyers you know
I'm saying well I mean I know for a fact
that the US government after World War
two recruited some of the top Germans
nice-lookin I get to the man before we
get to that dear but right now these
guys ended up coming all the way to
Alabama on a train and they had Italian
soldiers in with him two against if
Hitler was messing with some guy
Mussolini at that time in Italy or
whatever you feel me and these guys came
to my town or whatever but before this
43 44 1944 thing two years
before they brought those German
soldiers there guess who was there all
of the Korean not all the Korean all of
the Japanese in the country and I don't
think it was just Japanese I think it
was all Asian people can you google that
can we google it I know what y'all
google it at the house camp Aliceville
it was a pee owk Japanese powr Kel
because when Hiroshima happened the
United States was feeling like oh man we
had war with Japan
so we gotta lock up all the
japanese-americans yeah like well it was
this happened for real there was a lot
of there was a lot of espionage you're
going out with Pearl Harbor what they
can say that after that that's when they
started the concentration camps and they
were just pulling japanese-americans
that have been here for generations yet
out their homes and sending them to calm
seas you gotta say it a little different
they were put in japanese-americans that
built that [ __ ] railroad no that's
the Chinese oh that's Chinese I thought
it could have been what Japanese in
there now goddamn come on [ __ ] there are
all slanty-eyed bastards
man but I am so serious and y'all know I
don't have the Google it that is the
truth 100% now back to the German
soldiers I told you what happened with
the soldiers my granddaddy was there
today today came off and then that was
on one train then my granddaddy said
another train came who would a smart man
the man with glasses and I guess these
were the scientists in Germany and they
took these guys to another place I think
they took them to Huntsville Alabama
because we have a NASA program in
Huntsville that nobody talks about now
we used to go to the Space Camp up there
I just think and it's just me I think
that they know that Germany had
technology for those v2 rockets to go
all the way to Paris yeah I don't think
we could have made it to the moon I
don't think a lot of that [ __ ] wouldn't
happen without German scientists man
those guys those engineers are saying
well they were very very not worth our
time now watch this the Germans the
Germans was almost on some vandal [ __ ]
almost right almost murder they do first
huh
what did they do they weren't no no no I
mean just just just period saying that
Germany saying it they're so smart
people that uh if people that are taking
over and killing your people I won't say
today too smart but they get smart for
having the technology so I'll just ask
where did Germany get their technology
from I mean they were just advanced
people at the time no I think they've
got the technology from at that time
Hitler was in Africa when they got when
they got when they won the war stop he
was in Africa matter of fact the guy
that I broke into his house I'm sorry
one of the KKK dudes I broke into his
house and I saw the German uniform in
there what it had sorry but it had
Africa I wanted to find the information
I want to know what the KKK would do is
I broke in the house and I saw a World
War two uniform and I was like damn what
the [ __ ] is they're doing here
but what tripped me out was it had a
patch on the side that had Africa desert
core because this is the real battalion
that Hitler had you know me and these
guys I saw map of Africa and the trail
coming down well he why was Hitler in in
Egypt you know I mean that's the big
question why was he there he was on his
way to go in the temples and get those
relics
a lot of history in that now Valley and
even on that country of Africa you know
what I mean that's beneficial to us we
talk different languages right the
rosetta stone that got found in Egypt
you know how did you know that no it got
found like in the eighteen hundreds with
Napoleon somebody from Napoleon army
because at this time in Egypt we talkin
1800s right now early 1800s you got
France and Great Britain inside of Egypt
now you know that mean fighting and then
Napoleon somebody Napoleon army found
the Rosetta Stone they couldn't really
decipher it but they knew it was
important and Great Britain was like
give us that goddamn rosetta stone and
Napoleon said or his generals was like
man [ __ ] that with teddys [ __ ]
stone and brick all this goddamn
Egyptian [ __ ] up in here and they was
like hold on calm down we'll talk about
it tomorrow and then I guess they had
their spies or whatever go into the
house where they had the Rosetta Stone
and take it back the next day they kick
France out of Egypt but before France
left Egypt France said we'll leave but
can we take our papers and stuff like
that cuz friends came there they didn't
come down for war these people came to
Egypt finding out things you know I mean
it came with 200 to 300 scholars and
stuff like that like these people were
literally rewriting pamphlets rewriting
what was going on and what Napoleon did
make no mistake about it Napoleon did
something that nobody else else did he
challenged the world with information at
this time there was no such thing as an
Egyptian you feel me in the early 1800s
Napoleon said everything was Greek based
you know I mean like Greek gods and
stuff like that Napoleon said listen I
got the real papers from Egypt so I can
prove that y'all greet you can't say
that there's no Greek origin of nothing
because I have the real information of
who the Greeks learn from so I will bust
up all of this education system if I
don't get my way so United States and
all the other powers said listen we got
a lot of [ __ ] going on we trying to
control [ __ ] what the [ __ ] do you want
in a bastard he said I want to go down
in history is that ok well what you want
is I want to be I want I want to be the
best general of all time I want to go
down at the biggest general is that ok
he said for real and Napoleon is in the
United States is in the u.s. Academy of
Arts so you have to ask yourself why is
a French soldier in the United States
Academy of Arts you fear me that was the
deal that was me you know what I mean
like serious this is this is serious
business right here man I'm sorry if we
don't
we can edit it if y'all don't want the
world to know coming I don't want to get
shot I don't do that what that right
there just sound like a miserable coming
in as though I did not like that word
that was a it's like a baby missile
though but like I say deaf rosetta stone
France had the first Egyptologist that's
when they said well we're gonna make
something called Egyptology and France
had the first Egyptologist I think it's
named John Paul shampo Leon you go to
the Museum in France you'll see how my
dad was here but it's foot on top of
pharoah Edna's so disrespectful speaking
of missiles shut up
Anthony brother go ahead speaking of
missiles we had a missile scare recently
well you didn't hear about that in
Hawaii dude we resume shooting [ __ ]
I'll run did y'all hear it too I mean it
just came through on the phone and the
text message knows like they alert under
the emergency when are you guys are you
telling me that Hawaii has a big [ __ ]
Amber Alert to get the [ __ ] out of it no
it's just me - announcing it - but
that's how I saw it was on the phone
okay like an eight is that 808 in the
morning I saw it I was hungover and I
was like I lived a good life put the
phone down one back to sleep man I just
closed the doors to my balcony month and
yeah don't stop the nuclear radiation
I'll take every time I think about
Hawaii I always think about Cooper
Gooding jr. on that little [ __ ] man
shooting that girl man for some reason
man so Hawaii got two hours it was two
three ah whoo
Maui Kauai in the kkona kkona and names
come from Kona is the active one right
that's the one with uh it's a volcano
it's like active volcanoes on there yeah
y'all going to places where active oh no
we didn't go to one man either okay so
why is - yeah all right you got Hawaii
has a pretty rich history dude it had
kings and [ __ ]
I really do they have some black history
they have the only royal palace in the
whole United States
because basically the u.s. came in and
stole Hawaii yes this is mine yes they
held the Queen hostage in her own palace
and then I was gonna tell you if you
didn't tell me yeah that's good that's
good this is mine
all right I love it but it was a weird
message to get well what about the happy
birthday did they do to our Hanukkah
haka Mohini I can't pronounce the name
I'm gonna disrespect your name but it's
like a birthday book there's a parade
that they do every year after the king
you know I go with a picture mom he's
like a look it's a calendar Kyle I can't
pronounce it and I suggest you don't eat
the helm because you will butcher some
[ __ ] you butchered your own name so
don't do it interesting I learned the
tour guide we took a little tour around
the island interesting I was like why is
everything in English and why what's up
with the written language he said why
didn't have a written language until the
colonisation and then they were like you
know what we're gonna turn this into in
ink so it's like in English translation
of the their their their spoken language
but they never had a written languages
it's crazy to me well I know I'm fluent
on Hawaiian history because I watched
Moana so that's basically where I get my
knowledge from all Hawaii I don't really
know that much about it but I do know a
little bit and you probably see Moana
seven times I had to see if I do it
alone I love the [ __ ] boob kids can
watch a movie within a short window
within the window over years that [ __ ]
now my water was the one cup about six
months ago now they're real and I had to
watch real to first yeah before I even
watch real one so I didn't know I have
you watch real handsome
I don't know it'd just be crazy talking
to y'all but you maybe had to have kids
but um Rio is about Brazil and these
blue birds one blue bird is it's almost
like it's almost like history again
because they start off with real
all the birds just getting up you see
the eggs hatching and then you see the
bird get up and then a mom and say okay
now get up and fly and then you learn
how to fly cuz everybody's flying and
you can look and then when there's one
bird get up he's the last egg the hatch
like this news still going you know he
already saw all the birds coming flying
out of their tree and getting up flying
now he's about to get ready to go do it
he was like okay I see it I see it and
then all of a sudden true-true
people started snatching the birds out
of everywhere you know saying so much
that he was like what the [ __ ] is and he
tripped over and he failed and he tried
to fly and he couldn't fly you feel me
because all this crazy stuff going on so
then he looked up all of a sudden boom
they put him in the cage so he basically
was a bird that didn't even learn how to
fly because he got taken out of his home
environment you found me I was that's
crazy though well yeah a lot of those
animated movies have some message names
you know what they should actually
heavy-handed with them since sometimes
ok I get it
everybody should treat each other nice
[Music]
blankie and why we can't have the people
instead of the animals that just happy
sometimes man you never know
alright that's a dress
[Music]
[Music]
Hey so we said everybody what's up Joe
my name is not Joe
[Music]
my name is actually Joe hey hey y'all
come to my ground my baby shower baby
shower I'm going to my grandma got a
baby step up from the Aki machine yeah
yo come on yo I like it I don't man I've
been doing myself down here in this
weather man yes these crowds just push I
gotta say this but you got a big guy
damn boy if you've never been to a hell
of a bird show I suggest you get you
some [ __ ] tickets cuz that [ __ ] be
packed I thought I was gonna be going
into a crowd of 10 people 11 people
turned out to be feeling left out
genuine stuff man I like that right down
man and they love comedy you know I
never watch this park here because heat
will never let me own it out that
[ __ ] Hannibal he's my friend but this
is my first podcast yeah that I've ever
been on
relations now I've been on some but I
usually come here like you know if they
interviewing somebody else then they be
like hey we got smoke over there on the
couch oh you want me come here night
[ __ ] out of here this is the first part
care that I've ever been invited to have
you and I love you guys for that man man
fresh set it off John Thank You Man and
can I dedicate this show to my grandma
me anyway literally I want to dedicate
this show to my grandmother brother
she's not dead and then like that we
found out she got a dildo with real skin
on it and we're still trying to find out
who's Kennedy of exactly my granddad had
a prosthetic foot but he still got his
real foot in the house they say she
graphed the foot it's the wrong story
hey when you retired you got a lot of
different strokes for different folks
[Music]
day number two law
[Music]
[Music]